Alice: 那个开始新记录的按钮怎么没了
Alice: Why is the button to start a new record gone?
Alice: 我失忆了吗
Alice: Am I losing my memory?
Shure:  你们都没啊
Shure: None of you have it either?
Shure:  好了
Shure: Alright.
Jake:你重启一下
Jake: Restart it.
Shure:  是不是没删
Shure: Maybe it wasn't deleted?
Shure:  没删就把眼镜关了
Shure: If it wasn't deleted, just turn off the glasses.
Shure:  重启一下就好了
Shure: Restart and it should be fine.
Shure:  2024
Shure: 2024
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:您您在哪号啊
Jake: Where are you exactly?
Jake:呃您您您能找到53号吗
Jake: Uh, can you find number 53?
Jake:5一一般来说我们都是让快递们找53
Jake: Usually, we tell the couriers to find 53 first.
Jake:然后他们就能找到31
Jake: Then they can find 31.
Jake:五五五五十三了
Jake: Fifty-three, got it?
Jake:您您先到53吧
Jake: You go to 53 first.
Jake:别的快递员都能找到53然后就找到31了
Jake: Other couriers can find 53 and then 31.
Jake:是是是您您您对您您53您您您先找53吧
Jake: Yes, yes, yes. You, you, you find 53 first.
Jake:别人都能找到
Jake: Others can find it.
Jake:噢噢是是是是唉
Jake: Oh, oh yes, yes, yes.
Jake:您您到您您您到53再给我打电话吧
Jake: You get to 53 and then call me.
Jake:要不行吧
Jake: Otherwise, it won't work.
Jake:哎御河区53号别人都能找着
Jake: Yes, Yuhe District, number 53. Others can find it.
Jake:对挨着挨着挨着
Jake: Right, right next to it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake:对宁宁找53号
Jake: Yes, find number 53.
Jake:53号好找53号好找
Jake: Number 53 is easy to find.
Jake:那您找找呗
Jake: Just try to find it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我好像看见你了
Jake: I think I see you.
Jake:我从巷子往外走哎
Jake: I'm walking out from the alley.
Jake:辛苦辛苦
Jake: Thanks, thanks.
Jake:这实在是无语了是
Jake: This is really frustrating.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:5152确实您这个还还算什么点
Jake: 5152, indeed, this is still quite a spot.
Jake:你看到我往前走又是个70多又是个80多
Jake: You see me walking forward, there's another 70, another 80.
Jake:我又上走那边去了
Jake: I walked up to that side.
Jake:辛苦啊拜拜
Jake: Thanks, bye.
Jake:成果如何
Jake: How did it go?
Shure:  叫醒了
Shure: Woke up
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Awesome
Shure:  哦我还没我还没洗漱
Shure: Oh, I haven't washed up yet
Shure:  我想起来了
Shure: I just remembered
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Oh crap
Jake:行你直播洗漱吧要不
Jake: How about you do a live wash-up?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:早啊
Jake: Morning
Jake:长痘了嗯
Jake: Got pimples, huh?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Alice: 你会煎吗
Alice: Can you fry it?
Jake:好像还没挂
Jake: Seems like it's not hung up yet
Jake:又忘了对不起
Jake: Forgot again, sorry
Jake:我去搞一下
Jake: Let me handle it
Shure:  就是怕有撞车
Shure: Just afraid of a crash
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey
Shure:  面包是在楼上吗
Shure: Is the bread upstairs?
Jake:嗯不知道啊
Jake: Hmm, no idea
Shure:  我记得不是买了两袋面包吗
Shure: Didn't we buy two bags of bread?
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure:  怎么剩一袋了呢
Shure: Why is there only one left?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure:  你昨天晚上偷偷吃了
Shure: Did you sneak some last night?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yep
Shure:  我爹
Shure: Oh my
Shure:  真没吃呢
Shure: Really didn't eat it?
Lucia: 楼下我昨天那个
Lucia: Downstairs, yesterday I...
Lucia: 昨天昨天放那个蛋清空间不够
Lucia: Yesterday, I put the egg whites there, not enough space
Lucia: 我就把其中一袋放楼下了
Lucia: So I put one bag downstairs
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah